well China shining a light on the Dark  Side of the Moon for the first time ever  China's Space Administration released  these images hours after an unmanned  rover touched down on a side of the Moon  that never faces earth China launched  the probe last month to study the  composition of the moon's far side  terrain which has many more craters than  the side we normally see and NASA is  giving us the best look yet at the most  distant object ever explored the updated  high-resolution image shows the reddish  snowman shaped rock known as the  ultimate to leave about 4 billion miles  from the Sun the new Horizons spacecraft  captured this image in a flyby on New  Year's Day  that's so cool it's like a potato chip  very expensive potato crust and far away